the red sox are back home to begin a
three-game series with the tampa bay
rays who not long ago we're looking up
at the sox but after a 2-8 road trip
boston sits four games behind the tampa
bay club the best way to put an end to a
skid like this is a great start eduardo
rodriguez goes for the red sox tonight
eduardo rodriguez is looking to build on
the momentum he took from his last start
going five innings striking out ten
rosania is in
first pitch of this game and a lighter
up the middle and a base hit into center
so a rose arena comes off the il
swinging the bat on the first pitch and
rockets it right back through the middle
one on one out for wander franco the
rookie
and that is gonna be in there he caught
him looking he does that a lot when he
strikes guys out he catches them
admiring the pitch and that's out number
two brings up diaz 253 he's over eight
times
got him to lunge a bit and he popped it
up on the infield long run for devers
he'll get there and the side retired he
allows a hit nothing comes to that the
red sox are coming up for the tampa bay
rays it's going to be right-handed luis
patino making his eighth start of the
season era 442 and 36 and two-thirds
innings of work duran playing in center
field did he get 196 with two homers and
five rbis swinging a line drive base
hitting the center field that was headed
for the pitcher's head then it took off
one on one out
ground ball sharply hit the third diaz
allow one over to first around the horn
it goes five to four to three and
that'll take care of boston here's
jordan luplow with nobody on and one out
here in the top of the second that's
gonna be in there for strike three sits
down luplow caught him admiring the
pitch that's the second strikeout
looking from that cutter it looks like
it's off the dish by a couple inches and
now he's just looking what a great pitch
i love the combination that he has going
with that changeup of cutter at the
moment looking for back-to-back case
got him
rising fastball at 94 to put away margot
they go in order crappy devers facing
luis patino
that one is ripped by debra's deep to
right rosarina back kissed it goodbye
it's into the bullpen raphael stings one
home run number 28
and the sox get on the board one to
nothing
did not take long for him to get that
swing saw a fastball through the hands
nice line drive swing that ball got out
in half a second one-nothing socks
here's jd martinez
and he goes up and gets the strikeout
swinging bit of a chase up there by jd
martinez
one away hunter renfro former ray
he hooks a line drive and that's gonna
be a fair ball all the way to the wall
run throw into second base an easy
double he really had an outstanding at
bat there so the two bagger brings up
vasquez the cheers swung on and popped
up
first base side luke lowe started back
now comes in brandon now says i've got
it
and gets over there to make the catch
and that will retire the side brandon
lowe's going to start it against the
lefty rodriguez who certainly has looked
good over these last six spanish and
attract deep to right god of it's fair
down the line and gone home run into the
right field corner for brandon lau he
just matched what devers did right
around the pesky pole and the race have
tied it at one so brandon lau on the
first pitch hits number 25. there's
another guy who can do that mike cenino
and he goes hacking 92 mile an hour
heater to strike him out and that is
four strikeouts already for eduardo
that's going to be in there he caught
him looking with a sinking fastball he
fans arose arena another k for eduardo
tied 1-1 bottom of the third
and
cutting them is he goes up with 97
and picks up his second strikeout the
one out nobody on and up comes the time
of the order kiki hernandez
he's swinging there and a shot to third
what a pick down there by diaz throw to
first in time
hernandez swinging three-and-oh on that
fastball and somehow yandy diaz comes up
with this down there and throws him out
yeah and when [ __ ] hernandez realizes
that there was a double clutch and then
he rolled it to first base basically
he's not gonna be real happy but that's
how hard he hit this
that's a rocket shot nobody on that'll
leave it for jaron duran the rookie
swung on and missed strength three
coutinho
whips durant on a fastball at 98 that
was out of the zone it went down and in
bogarts at first
one out
and a cut the moose 96 up an end to
strikeout martini the right-hander walks
his first man and the socks have
something going on first and second and
so hunter renfro trying to do something
against patino
high fly ball in the left center
margot back marco back he's backing up
and that ball gets out of here
home run hunter renfro deep into the
night
margot backed up hoping for a carom that
never came
the red sox get a big fly number 19 out
of renfrow and the soxer in the lead 4-1
well he knew he got an awful lot of it
and right there knew it was gone so a
three-run lead for boston already
pitched into the three-run lead now
against the raids will go up against
lukewall iran looking at another punch
out and i think he got what he did swung
on a missed he couldn't contain himself
and luplow fans number seven
wave dead and missed with the change up
which has been deadly for erod eight
strikeouts through five one out now two
men in scoring position for the middle
part of this order sanders hit into a
double plays also single to right field
3-1
popped into short left
meadows is going to make the catch
and cordero is going to stay at third
not deep enough so it's going to be an
intentional walk to devers to load them
up for jd martinez the 01 pitch to jd
martinez is hit in the air to center
but not that deep right to the edge of
the warning track now onto the track a
couple of steps but to the triangle and
met walmart go with all kinds of room
in third cruise at first one out so the
rays will get the potential tying run to
the plate and wander franco
and the o2 lifted into center field
going to drop for a base hit
tonino will score
and the rays pick up their second run on
an rbi single by franco rbi number 19
for franco as junino had to wait and
then scurry home no question he's going
to be able to scamper home he was able
to do just that this inning not nearly
over for the raise and the red sox gonna
go to that pen
so here comes salamura yandy diaz
and that's going to be in there and
caught him looking with the split and 93
as you say nobody throws it harder two
out from meadows
swing flared into left martinez to make
the catch
salamura with really good work there out
of the bullpen the new pitcher for the
red sox is garrett whitlock now the rays
with two men in scoring possession will
go to the bench g-man choi will pinch it
for zanino
99 and he sends one into left center
field that's gonna be off the scoreboard
out there margot scores the ball loose
on the throw back in
scoring his loud as well
and g-man choi at second base has come
through coming off the bench to tie this
game they've gone out to take a look at
g-man choi he apparently is going to
leave the game we'll wait for some word
on that loud draws the walk to load the
bases wendell's a good hitter 280 with
seven home runs makes very good contact
most of the time
ground ball right to [ __ ] he gobbles
that up and the red sox get out of it
red sox with the go ahead run on at
first in the eighth christian vasquez
trying to get going again he's over
three two strikeouts also popped up to
second base swan gonna miss he got him
on a slider for the dirt for strength
three and andrew kittredge continues to
dominate the american league overall for
the game 29 pitches 26 for strikes and
that'll send this game to the ninth all
tied up and matt barnes who gave up a
couple of huge home runs over the
weekend in toronto try and keep them at
bay and now they're loaded in the ninth
here's mejia
and a line drive up the right field side
base hit a
scores the ball gets
loose in that right field corner
the rays
will score
not only arose arena but franco
and meadows and the rays come up with
three
on that liner in the right and the ball
that skipped away francisco mejia with a
bullet down the right field line and the
rays have come all the way back and have
a 7-4 lead and matt barnes problems
continue first and second two down and
here comes martin perez out of the
bullpen first pitch loop towards center
field my drop might drop my drop it does
here comes mejia around third he will
score in the third base goes margot it's
a base hit for brandon lau
and the raised lead is now 8-4 here in
the night and now the red sox are down
to their final out
and the fastball is popped up
short left
bronco out there rosarian is there it's
going to be franco and the rays won this
one
it's an 8-4 final three up three down
for boston in the ninth inning the rays
score four in the top of the ninth to
break a 4-4 tie
[Music]